there was a fight we all wanted a couple
years ago yeah Jon Jones yeah is that
still possible now that he's gone up
it's not even that's like it's kind of
like the Alex thing where everyone's
like oh we need a fifth fight and
everyone's like everyone else is more
bricked up for that than me and him I'm
not interested in fifth fight with Alex
that's exactly unless he comes up and
gets another belt that's that's exactly
right most people are like look everyone
are three one you're gonna make it oh
it's 1-1 in MMA you got to do a third
one and I was like no one cares no my
thing is me and John's the same thing
even like on impulsive when they said
what they said I was like I thought it
was a joke and then he actually pull it
up and I was like Ah that's funny but
it's what it wait what happened with
just Giants gave him you know props I
guess from a martial arts perspective I
guess he said you know
he was asked the question like who are
you a fan of and he was like well
actually like I'm a fan of Israel oh oh
fire bro that's the thing it's like fire
if there's
promoting a fight and there's another
thing which is martial arts right there
is fighting that's absolutely like what
you know we were saying earlier about
like that when when they two guys part
each other but then they become you know
yeah yeah connection
um
ha
hahaha
so Izzy's an aliens
[Music]
constantly he's his father son
hey
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that it does I remember in Puerto Rico
that's a great story
[Laughter]
about a week ago okay let's go you
remember Puerto Rico Ash was never there
he's not a part of the story at all
one time
[Music]
okay
do you know what's funny
we believe we won a worldwide [__]
platform
and yeah
[Laughter]
the videographer who feels every moment
in your life
hey cut the cameras
as he said Jeff knows when to film
we have to figure that out